you know I keep meeting you slow down
until you break but stop keeps happening
I really thought I was done talking
about ghost in the shell until it
actually was going to come out and we
actually knew what the thing was but
they ok so there was released um this
sort of I don't know it's a little bit
of a scene it's a clip of scarlett
johansson as the major you know waking
up in the artificial body for the first
time and she'd be watched over by dr. we
hear a better dialogue and then we get
some more you know some trailer eat
stuff we get a little bit of voiceover
from the villain and from from the major
and so forth and I have been hanging on
this thing by a thread up to this point
I am I had really been teetering on the
edge of do I actually want to go to the
theater and see this and at this point
the answer is no I'm packing this office
the same place I packed Wonder Woman
which is that barring really stellar
reviews and specifically from like
hearing from people who I know whose
opinions I trust and who understand
where I'm coming from with my issues as
to why I am very cautious and kind of
don't want to see this barring people
showing me that what I'm afraid of is it
going to be the case I'm not going to
this thing so to just review and recap
real quick my initial concerns if you go
back to my earlier videos what I thought
was going to happen was that they were
just going to copy and paste the the
1995 anime film and they weren't going
to change anything and that I didn't
want to happen because that irritated
the part of me that that hates you know
dizzy remaking their animated classics
in live action I feel that it undermines
the original because now they're making
the real version when really all they've
done is strip mine it and just do the
exact same thing again that's what I
thought would come out or I didn't think
about that's that was my initial fear
that was my early videos on this thing
going I hope they don't do that what I
what we're seeing at this point doesn't
indicate to me my initial fear but it
indicates something I didn't
he was going to happen which was an
insane dumbing down of this film and
just in it at this point it's not even
boiling it down it is taking the visuals
of the original sticking it on a
template that has almost nothing to do
with the original product and this clip
has solidified my opinion of that couple
thing well not one major thing
specifically at this point we had again
they keep hammering the same thing that
in save your life they stole it which
I've said repeatedly I hate that line
and it really does seem like they're
certainly hinging the marketing and by
all and that to me said they're hinging
the movie on this concept and then they
had they had the major it was a voice
over line so it's possible it was an ad
in it might not appear in the film
itself it doesn't matter if this is how
the market in the movie this is what I'm
assuming the movies going to be and they
had her say I will have my revenge King
what they're taking a story and whatever
version of the story like whether it is
one of the series that was done whether
was the film the anime films that we're
done whether it's the manga they are
taking this story this concept that is
steeped in heady ideas about identity
artificial intelligence the future of
humanity the marrying of mind and
machine and they're turning it into a
revenge story revenge as never never
then the point or the focus of this you
are look at some of the various one a
notion of event has popped up now and
then but it's never been the point and
it's rarely even been used and like a
surface level motivation she's not out
for revenge came out out avenging her
pets into the whole thing her character
of the major especially it's about
questioning what she is and what she
could be and what she might be becoming
and then exploring that further revenge
is all about looking back it's about
what you lost it's about what we've
taken away from you it is about a venue
a strong the idea that the ghost in the
shell as a franchise is looking back
instead of into the future is it
absolute just complete dropping the ball
of the heart of this property and then
it's kind of a capper on this let's talk
about the fact that the major got a name
drop in this clip which is Mira and this
brings back the whole whitewashing thing
again now I did a separate video on that
as well and at the time in that video I
alluded to but didn't go into a lot of
depth of the fact that certain people
could if they want to make a narrative
argument for why it is ok that the major
was a Caucasian woman I didn't go into
detail at that point but what I was
alluding to with something that I've
seen repeatedly a number of people bring
up as a possibility for why casting
Scarlett Johansson is not that big a
deal now I'm not saying I necessarily
agree with this argument but the
argument basically goes because the
story takes place in this cyber punk
future and because the major is in an
artificial body her race is only a
reflection of the body she is in and it
is no way an indication of the reishi
was prior to becoming this physical form
now doesn't actually gloss over the
issue that people who cry whitewashing
are trying to point out issues of you
know representation and whatever no it
absolutely doesn't but that argument was
one that people were still making and
the fact that it could be made basically
a lot of people who maybe were on the
fence and felt a little awkward about it
but still wanted to see the movie it
allowed them the sort of space that in
their hand cannon to say look we don't
know what she was you know before she
was in this body she could have been any
nationality now she just happens to be
this and to sort of square that circle a
little bit for themselves which I think
for some people is just a way to try and
allow them to see it was see the movie
without a lot of baggage and up until
this clip and the name drop of Mara they
had the ability to do that Mira Mira is
not a Japanese name I actually even
looked into
to the roots of the name and it's got a
couple different origins because it
comes from a couple different places
there's some Slavic groups there's Latin
roots you know romance languages asian
languages Japanese any of that whole
ridge of the world not on the list does
that mean that an Asian woman can't be
named merit no of course not but it
really kind of takes the wind out of
that argument which means that from
where I sit the whitewashing thing is
now a bigger I'm not sure if it's a
bigger issue the issue it always has
been what it has been but it's now a lot
harder to defend that it was before and
I was shocked they even drop the name I
had assumed that they would just call
her the major throughout the whole thing
and never even you know say what her
name was before that because that would
again have allowed for this wiggle room
for this sort of people to make henkins
people to make an argument and again not
saying it was necessarily a valid
argument but there was at least room
where somebody could make that and
people have been and not now I don't
know it if that name drop is actually
going to renew as you know the
whitewashing accusations or whatever any
more than they already were but if for
people who are still having that
argument the decides that we're trying
to say that it wasn't a big deal or
maybe it was something out today they
don't really have much just much of a
leg to stand on anymore and I think that
puts the film in a weaker position and
and it just it is one more thing to add
to the pile of reasons why I don't want
to see this now like I said I'm not
saying definitively that I will never
see this one thing right now is the
movie as I have come to understand it
based on the marketing and again you
know people can tell me all day long you
know they maybe they're just doing this
to get butts in seats and I accept that
that's a possibility but I'm not going
to look at a piece of marketing and
assume it's lying to me unless it's
coming from JJ Abrams I'm going to
assume that what they show me is
representative of the film and I don't
want what they're showing me at all so
where is it right now I'm not going to
pay money to see this movie so it leaves
one of two possibilities if the reviews
are stellar and if
when I dig into the substance of the
reviews it seems like the things I was
afraid of are not the case I will then
go and give it a fair shot if that
doesn't happen if the reviews are
mediocre or if the reviews are decent
but it does in fact look like all the
things I'm afraid of were in fact done
and are in fact the case then on you
know when it eventually turns up on
netflix or something and I can see it
without having to pay money directly for
that movie yeah maybe I'll catch it just
so I can sort of know for myself if all
my assumptions were correct but i'm not
paying theater prices based off my
current understanding of what this movie
is so I I want to say this is the last
video I'm going to make on this
live-action ghost in the shell but you
know what I thought that about the last
one so I'm not going to say that i will
say i would like this to be the last
video that i have to make about this
movie but we'll see so go from the shell
play this clip did you like it did you
not like it do you watch it and watch me
talking about and go why is this a big
deal whatever your thoughts were drop
something down in the comments let's
talk about it don't forget to Like
subscribe check me out on twitter
accounts of geeks give it a listen to
the counsel of geese podcast available
on iTunes and stitcher and until next
time the council isn't jerk
Oh